hi youtube this is ariana
secretary-general of the organisation
for economic co-operation and
development oecd okay so the question is
do you feel the environmental results of
the economy of the environment should
not must not and I'm doing everything I
can so there will not lose to the
recession to the economy there are some
things we have to tackle immediately we
have to tackle the banks and stability
they have to lend again those packages
of stimulus in order to get the economy
working again but we cannot forget the
medium and the long term issues the
climate change the poverty the Doha
round we have to close that and by the
way we may be in better shape than we
think because many of these stimulus
packages have a big content that is
supposed to be a green that creates the
jobs but also green jobs at Green
Investment so we should make sure that
the green content is as much as we can
get in